good afternoon everyone
good afternoon everyone
thank you all for coming out this
evening
my name is brandon randleman i'm a local
political activist
it's not working
this evening how's everyone doing can
you hear me
good afternoon and thank you all for
coming out this evening
my name is brandon randleman i'm a local
political activist
a native of windsor virginia a graduate
of virginia state university
and today we are all here standing in
solidarity
with army lieutenant karan nazario
to discuss the egregious events that
took place on december 5th
2020 and and to discuss our plan of
action
moving forward for our community there's
a quote that often comes to mind
when these situations occur and it says
there comes a point in every man's life
when he has to say enough is enough
and today we are standing here as
african-american citizens
and leaders and we are saying to this
town of windsor
to the commonwealth of virginia and to
the united states of america
that we as black and brown individuals
have been targeted by the unjust
and unfort unfair criminal justice
system
for far too long and enough is enough
we have to make one point very clear
the stop that was initiated was due to
tinted windows
and the license plates being in a
different location
on his vehicle please let that sink in
at this bp behind us guns were
immediately drawn
by the police officers and the situation
for koran
could have ended a whole lot worse
because of a minor traffic stop
for tinted windows and a license plates
lieutenant rosario did everything
correctly
during this traffic stop he slowed down
and pulled over into a well-lit area
he placed his hand out the window and he
politely asked
what he was being pulled over for but in
return
these police officers drew their weapons
on him immediately
they taunted him with statements they
made during the stop
they pepper sprayed him and they use
physical
force for in the arrest this is the
treatment
of an african-american military officer
received by our local law enforcement
that's why we are demanding full
and complete transparency from the town
of windsor
and the windsor police department
regarding all individuals
that were involved in this matter as a
windsor native
and a former student of virginia state
university
these traffic stops are all too common
on route 460. the route 460 corridor
in which this incident occurred on
serves as a main connector
for many african-american students and
their parents
as they travel between virginia state
university
and norfolk state university two of our
largest hbcus
in the commonwealth of virginia this is
a stretch of road
that has become a bad rock for speed
traps
for many drivers as they travel through
these small towns
after speaking with with our community
citizens
we believe that african americans
have been cited for traffic violations
at a disproportionately higher rate on
route 460.
in the coming days we will be speaking
with our state and federal officials
and requesting that the appropriate
investigations occur
to ensure that minority civil rights
have not been violated
over the years while traveling on route
460.
let me be clear we all share one common
goal up here
and that is that we will no longer stand
by
silently because dr king said the best
injustice anywhere
is a threat to justice everywhere thank
you
we will now have remarks from our
esteemed president ms valerie butler the
president of the alawite county naacp
chapter
good afternoon i guess i don't need to
introduce myself since brandon
introduced me
well anyway my name is valerie butler
and i am president
of the local branch of the alabama naacp
i want to thank you for coming out to
our press conference this afternoon
i also like for you to know that we have
been in communication
with lieutenant rosario's attorney
he states thanks for the work that you
are doing
my client is behind you agrees with what
you are doing and appreciates it
after reviewing the video there are
several
areas of concern by the alawite naacp
and our local community here in windsor
we want to
reiterate the initial stop occurred
because of the location of lieutenant
rosario's
license plate and tenet windows
lieutenant rosario did what many of us
have done
that live in this rural community when
the police signaled for him to stop
he slowly pulled over into a well-lit
area but this stop resulted in weapons
being immediately drawn
the use of pepper spray and physical
force
by the police to an active duty
military officer in uniform
there are so many things that went wrong
with this traffic stop
but it is indicative of what is
happening around the country
and how officers walk away from
cases with no disciplinary action to
include
termination and or firing that is why
today
we are demanding the following actions
number one we are expecting transparency
from the town of windsor
and the police department we want
answers
to the following when did the
investigation
initially began we heard that it began
when the incident happened
but is that what really happened and
when was it concluded
regarding the dc december 5th traffic
stop
when was officer guterres
officially terminated were any
disciplinary actions taken against
officer crocker and his officer crocker
still patrolling our neighborhoods here
in windsor
if so we are immediately calling
for his termination he needs to be fired
also
we are requesting that the police
department provide to the public
what their newly implemented training
requirements
are with respect to traffic stops in the
town of windsor
we and the public deserves to know that
number two we are thankful that governor
northam has acknowledged
this injustice and has taken steps to
correct this issue
however after speaking to minority
members in our community
we would like for an independent body
outside of law enforcement
to investigate the circumstances
surrounding the december 5th
traffic stop therefore we are asking the
commonwealth of virginia
to give our elected attorney general
the authority to investigate this
incident
in its entirety we are also
calling on state attorney general mark
herring's office
of civil rights to investigate patterns
or practices
of bias policing during traffic stops
in the windsor police department and
number three
we stand with the virginia state
conference
of the naacp to call on governor northam
to call a special session of the general
assembly
to pass house bill 2045
ending qualified immunity for police
officers
police officers are sworn to protect and
serve our community
posted on the windsor's police website
they state their core values are honor
integrity courage and commitment
we thank those police officers who
uphold those core values
and who put on their uniforms every day
to protect
and to serve the citizens to the highest
standard
but it is imperative that these
upstanding police officers encourage
all of their field appears on the force
to do the right thing in the coming days
we will submit letters to all of the
government officials mentioned today
we are expecting response from them and
a proposed plan of action
for the windsor community we will
encourage the public
to continue to support lieutenant
rosario
and the endeavors of the alawite chapter
of the naacp
now i'd like to introduce delegates don
scott
and jeffrey bourne
good afternoon good evening um i just
want to thank
um the members of the iowa county branch
naacp
uh and the community members uh from
windsor for having me down here
um as as the two previous speakers have
mentioned we yet again
see what happens when the ugly head of
institutional
and systemic racism rears its ugly head
in our law enforcement ranks we have
lieutenant rosario
a man who is serving this country in
uniform
pulled over for a pretextual stop
something very very minor and as has
been said
he did what we all do when we're when
we're in places
uh that are dark we pulled a light
well-lit area
where we feel safe and so
i'm here to lend my support
lend my commitment to work on uh the
bill for qualified and sovereign
immunity
because it's one piece and i'm not here
to suggest
that that is the end-all be-all to
really righting the wrongs in our
criminal justice system
we have to do we have to fully examine
our use of force standards across the
state
and it might be time for a statewide
standard
we need to figure out how we fund our
police and law enforcement officers
and what we fund we need to really
double down on de-escalation training
we need to really hunker down and figure
out which
and who off which officers we're hiring
who these people are
because they don't learn this stuff on
the job when they're hired
and so
i don't want to trespass on your time uh
any longer but i will say this i know
i'm committed
and i know my good friend don scott is
committed to doing
anything and everything possible with
our role in the state legislature
to continue the good work that we've
done over the last several months
because we passed a bill in the summer
that made these types of stops for minor
traffic infractions
illegal and unfortunately it was too
late
for lieutenant rosario
but hopefully
[Music]
and thankfully it won't be like too late
for other drivers
and i heard the president say she called
on the attorney general
to investigate the patterns in practice
unfortunately i believe
don you correct me if i'm wrong the
attorney general has agreed to do that
just as i was pulling in
so we're glad to see him move from a
moderate monitoring
and wait and see out of tune to actually
actively using
some of the uh authority and power that
the legislature has granted him so i
thank you for your time
and at some point i guess we'll answer
questions but let me turn it over to
delegate don scott
[Applause]
i'm gonna be very brief one one of the
things that um
i'm a former naval officer myself and
one of the things that made me sick to
my stomach
was to see this man in uniform
being disrespected in the manner in the
way that he was treated
it was shameful it was embarrassing it
was disgusting
neither one of those officers who
perpetrated those acts
should be wearing a uniform right now
they should not be in this community
doing this type of work
that's one two my good colleague jeff
warren has
brought this uh bill to unqualified
immunity but we know qualified immunity
alone that gives you financial
compensation for harm's cause
but it doesn't prevent the things that
from happening there is a law on the
state code right now called the law
enforcement procedural guarantees act
take a look at it it protects officers
when they get in trouble they do
something wrong it gives them more due
process rights
than the average citizen we have to take
a look at that and then lastly
we have to look at the officers on the
job
these people so a friend of mine used to
do a lot of corporate training
and he said culture eats training for
lunch
the culture in this in this organization
as demonstrated by those two officers
means that this was acceptable it was
the norm they did not feel like they
would be punished
even when they saw this man was wearing
a army uniform
protecting their own lives abroad they
still felt very comfortable
disrespecting him and abusing him so
what i'm saying is that some people
that's not fit to ever wear
that uniform it's not it's bigger than
defunding the police
it's bigger than uh police and practice
building police accountability
some of these guys should not be in
uniform in the first place
they are not fit to do the job they
don't have the temperament
to do the job they don't have a
professionalism do the job and they
don't have the restraint to do the job
so hopefully as we move forward here in
the next weeks uh we'll get some more
answers
what i heard the madam president say
that we need to know
when did the investigation begin what
type of discipline because that's an
important question
did it only begin they started taking
steps after
you know there was after they found out
they got caught or did they do something
earlier
even uh even now the attorney general to
his credit now
has come out today i just saw a memo
that he's going to start at patterson
practices investigation
here in windsor but he needs to do the
same thing in virginia beach
he needs to do the same thing in some
other cities where these things are
still going on it's time for him
to stop being uh stop standing on the
sideline and take action
and start protecting our communities
thank you and i'm happy to step aside
[Applause]
good evening i'm daquan love state
executive director for the virginia
state conference
naacp president robert barnett who was
unable to be with us
asked me to provide brief remarks i'm
joined
this evening of course with our local
branch president
uh valerie butler from the isle of
wright branch we have with us from other
branches uh galen kenoit and our
regional vice president james boyd did i
miss any other branch
presidents i don't think i did uh but we
are standing here in solidarity
uh as afer mentioned this is not just
about
one traffic stop and we cannot let it be
just about one traffic stop
this is about decency
justice and frankly accountability
to tell us that a black
army second lieutenant
in uniform can have
that type of treatment imposed upon him
imagine what happens when the body
cameras are off
imagine what happens and on dark roads
across the length and breadth of this
commonwealth the virginia naacp
says enough is enough and that's why we
have launched
a statewide campaign to call for the end
of qualified immunity and we're
demanding
that governor ralph northam call for a
special session
to bring by community for law
enforcement officers
to end absolutely
we want folks at home here
in the community to go to demand a
special session.com
that's demand specialisation.com
and sign our petition as of this
afternoon we already have
1500 signatures on our online petition
calling for governor ralph northam to
just call a special session
ladies and gentlemen the time for
statements and sympathies is over
we deserve action and we deserve it
right away
president and ceo derek johnson just
said on cnn a few moments before i
pulled up here
as it relates to this and other
instances across the country
if there were not a if now is not
the time that we need the naacp i don't
know what time that might be
and so the naacp our units across the
commonwealth will fight
and we will continue to fight and we
will continue to persist
until qualified immunity for law
enforcement officers finally
comes to an end with that that does uh
conclude the speaking program for this
session
we will uh begin opening for questions
and answers
i know uh i'm not sure if the delegates
will have i know they have to
get back on the road but i will answer
questions from the naacp
if you could please identify your name
in your media outlet
and then we'll answer your questions
i'm sorry i can't hear you
why is it that no one is calling
for a federal investigation of the cia
fbi and all of the
there is an agencies of racist
companies embedded into
our law enforcement community especially
in small towns like suffolk
windsor brunei waverly employer
and uh colonial rights
when will there be
an investigation from the federal side
this man
when they attack that officer
in the uniform they attacked all of us
they attacked america and that is why
the federal government needs to come in
and root out
these uh while i'm a reporter
these rednecks who
serve no basis other than promoting
their own attendance of racism
and hate will you ask for the
congressional
and the senate delegation to come in and
ask for
a clearinghouse of the federal review of
investigation
let me be unequivocally clear the naacp
local state and national levels are all
working in concert
on this issue of police brutality
and law enforcement officer
accountability and that's exactly why
our local
branch has called for some
accountability measures here in the town
of windsor the state naacp is calling
for measures from the state level
and i know our national office through
our washington bureau
is also looking at other ways we are
able to address this we are done dying
and we will ensure that uh law
enforcement
and law enforcement uh officers are held
accountable
next question please thank you so much
i know that the president did read a
statement from from the lieutenant's law
attorneys earlier this afternoon um and
and
so we are in contact with uh them and
what we will say is this
we are focused on ensuring in
accountability ensuring transparency
and that policies are changed to prevent
this from happening again
next question how do y'all from brody
young live on
tv yes thank you me and my girls want to
know
what would it take for us as people to
make a change inside
like the congress the senate and things
like that what would it take for us as
community the community
to make a change or bring a change
involved well here's the first thing
that folks can do
then you need to call your state
legislator your delegate and your senate
and everybody has one here in the
commonwealth
and call and ask them what is their
position on ending qualified immunity
and ensuring
uh law enforcement officers are held
accountable uh
this bill came up just this past session
it came up in special session
and and it clearly we did not have the
votes that we needed to
and so for everyday folks can call their
state legislator
they can ensure that their legislator is
supportive of these measures
but moreover we have to look out for one
another
in common sense making sure that we are
uh
supporting common sense uh reforms that
were are going to make sure
that justice is served and transparency
happens did you have something you
wanted to add president but i think that
we have legislative days
at capitol hill you know if there are
issues and concerns that we
are concerned about then we need to show
up pay a visit to our legislators
how did the town make a decision from
which officers to actually fire
it was actually officer crocker's
uh traffic stop and the other officer
actually tuned in with him you know i'm
making the assumption that
i was told by the town manager here that
they had had some extensive training
since this incident in december
clearly this traffic stop is not
indicative of that
and a traffic stop does not warrant
police officers getting out of their car
with guns drawn if they stopped him for
a missing license plate
they approached the vehicle from behind
they should have seen his license
uh shown in his back window
that should have been enough evidence to
at least deter
the manner in which they approached him
and they should have had
a calming uh conversation with him you
know police officers
should de-escalate um the situation
and in this particular case it was
lieutenant rosario
who actually tried to de-escalate it but
the officers continued to escalate it
i'm sure he's capable of
retraining i don't know that but i think
that in this day and time
was indicative of happening around the
country we could not afford
another traffic stop to happen
lieutenant rosario
um was fortunate that there were no guns
fired
but what will happen with the next
traffic stop and i think both police
officers need to be fired
and i want to add on to that just
briefly here it should not take a
federal lawsuit
for the town to actually come out with
this information
that's that's what folks need to
understand it should not take what had
to happen
uh if we're four months later uh it
wasn't until the local branch
made a press statement i know the state
conference made a press statement
and late sunday night that's when the
town decided to release that information
and there's still some unanswered
questions
it shouldn't we should not take this
much to get these questions so rather
than talking about
the police officer being retrained why
don't we talk about making sure that
black virginians
feel comfortable and safe when they're
approached by law enforcement
what is the conversation it's been
between either naacp
leaders here and with the police
department
and the city because obviously they sent
out the press release
later after this incident and that
they're being broke but has there been
consistent dialogue between
these questions about whether or not why
the investigation
took place when it took place at the
time it ended but
has there been a consistent dialogue
even before this between the double atp
and local leaders
and the police department and the uh
town or this that's just not exactly
it is existing here um
the naacp uh has a concern about
criminal justice
and i know on a regular basis we have
met
with the police departments on the
northern end of the county
have a very good working relationship
with the alawite sheriff's department
as well as the town of smithfield police
department
i do not know the police department
here as well i have had the opportunity
to have a sit-down conversation with the
chief of police here
we have met with them a couple of times
but it was planned to be an
ongoing process but with the pandemic
coming about
you know we kind of backed off some
situations um
we met with them about a year ago so
you know based on what's happening in
the community now
that is a focus that we plan to continue
we have also worked with the police
department to try to get them more
engaged
in the community too so that people in
the community will feel comfortable with
them
when they see them out patrolling one
last question from really good live tv
um do you think it's not enough of us
coming out inside our homes
and voting so we can make a change
inside of like the
senate office of um is the city
councilman
do you think more of us need to come
outside our homes low-income communities
and vote these people out so we can
bring change inside of the office
that's a very good question um one of
the projects that we
are working on uh currently now
especially with the primary and the
general election we're both
we're working on voter registration but
it's not only voter registration we're
also working on voter education um
we had a couple of protests last year
when when the george floyd incident
happened and people were protesting
and it was a positive thing that
happened in our county because we were
able to get growth in our membership
we've made commitments to those
communities
in which people feel that their vote
don't count
um a very good example of what happened
in georgia this past election
you see with people getting out going to
the polls and actually vote
voting you know what it can mean i think
that
we need to incur and educate our
citizens
that their vote is more important on the
local level
because that's the level where in which
they're going to be more
it and we have already started our voter
race
registration process we've had a couple
of voter registration pop-up events
you know already um we have some
local positions that are coming becoming
available
um we're trying to recruit people to
encourage them
if they want to make a difference in
their community then they need to run
for public office they need to run for
school board
so there are some of the things that
we're working with
and working with the protests one of the
things that i did discover
we had one protest that was actually
initiated
by a virginia tech sophomore and i had
the opportunity to meet with these
people
they are so angry with what's happening
especially with police brutality
unlike myself i like things in order to
go about the right way
she said miss butler that's your
generation our generation is not going
to stand back
and sit and be complacent with what's
happening
again it's things like that that keep me
motivated
to want to make a change and i'm hoping
that
we will see some differences in the town
of windsor
the population here is 73 white
and 18 black it's not about who's in
majority
it's about justice and doing the right
thing
this
the new way and civil rights were
violated
although what you are saying from the
state level is fine
but these are the possibility
issues
all we're going to get is bureaucracy
and cover-up i get down in virginia
beach
with the donovan lynch murder and the
same thing here
i grew up around here i've got relatives
all back here this has been going on i'm
67 years old this has been going on for
ever since i can remember and it's a
shame and a disgrace
that we have these redneck cops that
have infiltrated
the recent pockets of
we got the opportunity now the man was
in compliance on video
declaring that he was afraid to get out
of the car so i'm asking you why the
hell
are we sending them being bloody donated
with this
so we have been in contact with uh the
congressional delegation and we are
continuing to have conversations with
members of the congressional
delegation you're absolutely right we
definitely need action which is why
we're calling for an end to qualified
immunity
here in the commonwealth and folks can
go to demand a special session.com
so they can sign that online petition
and call on governor ralph northam
to bring the legislators back into
session are there any other questions
yes but you say that
they have their own thing
they want the training harvey it wasn't
and that's another part of my boy
you gotta have respect for people here
that's good
make you the most powerful person in the
world
because you don't know what to do with
it but pouring it in from that
you know but
they don't have respect for them and i
think they're hungry
they don't want to stop that i want this
problem
they don't bother i see it every day
we really appreciate that and we want to
thank everyone for coming out this
evening uh this does conclude our press
conference and we
uh uh we if you have any additional
questions the media contact is on the
press advisory we'll be happy to address
those questions there
thank you i do know that president uh
butler and myself
i will be made available if you'd like
one-on-one interviews as well
thank you
thank you thank you
thank y'all
here
let
but that's one thing i want somebody to
talk about
how is it that they are the only ones
that's all i ever see them stop
am i free to get off live now
go in there and make it
you